one of the biggest successes we've had
with liquid is simulating quantum
chemistry we spent a lot of time
building a tailored simulation system so
that we could do some interesting
chemicals we can't go much bigger than
about 30 cubits on a classical machine
but that's enough to do some interesting
chemical analysis we can also build
circuits for much bigger systems for
real quantum computers on the order of
one to two hundred qubits but we can't
run them we can look at gate counts we
can look at how long they would take to
run on the quantum computer and that's
what's important so we started with an
interesting problem which is a chemical
called ferredoxin fe 2 s 2 this little
chemical sits at the heart of
photosynthesis it's also in your
bloodstream your hemoglobin is used as
an energy transport to move other
molecules around quantum chemists would
like to analyze this chemical but the
problem is the molecule has irons in it
and irons have d orbitals which are
notoriously hard to simulate on a
classical computer so we looked at how
hard this would be when we first started
the accepted state of the art for how
they thought they would do this on a
quantum computer if you ran the numbers
came out to a circuit that would take 24
billion years to run on a quantum
computer now that sounds terrible but to
run it on a classical computer would
have been longer than the lifetime of
the universe so actually it's a big win
but it doesn't make it down to human
timeframe over the course of 2015 we
wrote for papers doing research in this
area and we can each paper lowered the
time it would take to actually run this
on a quantum computer until the final
paper we got down to one hour from 24
billion years pretty good speed up and
the papers are referenced on the website
after this video if you'd like to see
the papers themselves I'm bringing this
up because one of the interesting points
here is how did the quantum simulator
help us the one thing liquid did is it
let us try some small chemicals and
small molecules and these small
molecules when we simulated them
simulated much much faster too much
higher accuracy than the theoretical
results would have told us many many
orders of magnitude faster so we're able
to go back to the theorists and say are
you sure about the theory missed oh no
you're not simulating everything is it
well we're getting the right answer try
this molecule we tried that molecule we
went back and forth and after while the
theorists realized that chemistry has
some very specific things about it which
are documented in the papers that we
could actually do much smaller circuits
and run them much fewer amounts of time
to get the same accuracy so this was a
good example where a quantum simulator
even with only on the order of 30 cubits
was able to inform a result for future
quantum computers that maybe 10 20 years
away of how hard something would
actually be to run and what you could
really accomplish with a quantum
computer we're now looking into first
level problems things like better
fertilizer algorithms different ways for
making fertilizer with less energy
carbon capture to solve global warming
all of these fit in this quantum
chemistry area and we're doing a lot of
work now to see what would you do with
the earliest quantum computers that can
actually run this size problem